this is gonna i don't mean to drop into
like one percent privilege but i think
most people are working too hard
um i think most people are just
basically
spinning wheels and spending a lot of
time and make work and the older you get
the better you get at just declining
work that you know is useless like i
have this theory that 99 of work that
you do is useless you still have to do
it because it's entering iterating your
way to the one percent that is useful
but in an ideal world if you're
omniscient you would just cut to the one
percent
so for example 99 of people that you
went on dates with you didn't end up
marrying so that wasn't the final answer
99 of stuff you learned in school you're
forgotten you weren't really curious
about it doesn't apply to your life
anymore 99 of the presentations you did
at work the spreadsheets the code that
you wrote got thrown away didn't account
for the returns now of course you had to
do that to build up the expertise for
the one percent that worked or perhaps
was trial and error you should do it to
find the one percent that worked but as
you get older you just get better at
figuring out well actually instead of
taking 100 shots on goal to get the one
that works i'm actually going to narrow
it down so i take 10 or 20 or 30. and a
lot of judgment is just knowing not what
to do in the first place the ability to
say no and be correct that that was a no
is a superpower you want to be able to
filter out things very efficiently and
that just comes to experience but if
you're becoming more and more
experienced and you aren't filtering
projects and firing customers and not
pursuing certain marketing strategies
and declining working with certain kinds
of people and even turning away the
money when it doesn't make sense if
you're not doing that then you're not
gonna then you're not gonna scale
properly
so i do think that a lot of people just
end up spending a lot of time in busy
work and make work we're also in this
odd society where we think that well
every degree takes four years isn't that
a coincidence whether you're becoming an
expert in art history or architecture or
computer science or physics it takes
exactly four years what a heck of a
coincidence every job takes eight hours
a day five days a week whether you're
coding up the next cryptocurrency or
whether you're
marketing something or whether you're hr
or whether you're a receptionist it
takes the same amount of hours what a
coincidence obviously i'm being
facetious obviously that's not correct
so we have these one-size-fits-all rules
that don't make any sense and yet we
look around and some of the most
successful people in the world warren
buffett you know that guy makes like one
decision a year that matters he spends a
lot of time reading books a lot of time
playing bridge and he's one of the
richest man in the world so it's not
really about hard work elon musk is
working around the clock but he's also
partying hard he's dating he's tweeting
he's running multiple companies he's
driving cars he's moving around he's
engaging in politics he's getting sued
by the sec busy guy where does he find
the time for all this the guy at the
corner convenience store is working 80
hours a week i don't see him being any
more successful than elon musk or even
close to that so clearly hard work
although it's important it's an element
it's one leg of the stool it's probably
not the most important one and you can
definitely make trade-offs as you get
older and wiser about working less hard
but working more smart it's very very
true and especially in the age of
leverage that we live in judgment just
gets magnified one little decision
magnified a thousand times hundred
thousand times million times that's why
you see such outsized fortunes one
person decides to code up a face mash at
harvard and they become facebook the
other one decides to code up something
that you've never heard of because it
was close but not quite it just hit
number 100 in the app store for a week
and then it was gone so it's not really
about hard work it's about judgment so
hard work is important to the extent
that it builds up judgment but
eventually when you have the judgment
you should be saying no all the time
yeah i mean i think also over time you
you have capital uh right you have
credibility you have potentially just
money that you can pay people to do the
work
which is something a lot of people you
you kind of i think that sort of stuff
yeah you have to figure out how to do
the thing that you like to do all the
time or at least make free free the
calendar well there's a three forms of
leverage and you should employ all of
them one is labor so outsource anything
that is less than your hourly rate and
set your hourly rate to an aspirational
level another is uh capital which is you
can when you make a decision you invest
capital behind it so you multiply the
force that you're exerting through the
free markets and the last of course is
through creating a product or which
could be writing it could be a podcast
it could be a an actual physical product
or it could be a piece of code that has
no marginal cost of uh of replication
and that last form of leverage is
largely permissionless and the most
powerful modern form of leverage and
that's where the modern fortunes are
built the older ones were built on
capital and the oldest ones were built
on labor if you want to get rich in the
1700s or 1800s
you did it with labor you wanted to get
rich in the 1900s you did with capital
you want to get rich in the 2000s you do
it with code maybe media
where do you think crypto like fits into
this i mean i feel like it
you know someone someone had this
question so let me ask this question
which is about investing
um you said somewhere apparently that
most people are going to be investors in
the future especially when full-scale
agi kicks in that seems like maybe not
something you'd say exactly but
that's something that apology said
actually a technology quote um and i'm
not biology but i think i know what he
meant he's basically saying we're going
from an economy where most people are
labor to where most people are capital
we're going for most people being
workers to most people investors this
trend started with a 401k
crypto makes it even easier and you know
cryptos like this giant casino in which
you can invest in stocks bonds
derivatives options all this venture new
blockchains new protocol stuff that was
traditionally closed off and only
accredited sophisticated investors and
now everyone can invest in it so it's
sort of creating this mentality of
everyone's an investor owner which is a
good thing right everyone's a everyone's
a laborer and everyone's a capitalist
and ideally i think the highest form
beyond labor and beyond capitalist is
creator everyone's a creator everyone's
either creating product or they're
creating code or they're creating media
they're creating ideas they're creating
books they're creating podcasts creating
youtube they're getting twitch what have
you but the creator economy in that
sense is the apotheosis it's the highest
level above the labor economy above the
capitalist economy it's a creator
economy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you